Hôm 12 giờ không nay 2 tháng 12 năm, nhưng hôm 12 năm,
tại cú rộn năm, địa phận phường tụi mình,
thêm phó hải phòng sế ra vụ tên an chào thông đến hoàn dưới nhiều sếu tục.
Theo đó, sẽ đầu kéo 12 xe,
một bà hai một bún,
gió tại sếng vĩnh văn tê,
sinh năm 1870, chí trong bệnh mi tư,
chú hải phòng, đưa khiến hưởng hạn nội đi hải phòng,
đã tôn vào đuôi sếu tư tại,
sau đó đổi sế tại và trạm dùnh toàn đến tiếng 12 xe cùng chíu phi trước,
hậu qua, 2 người thử vòng, bông người bị thương,
bẩy phương tình hương hồng.
Quà sắp bị xe bộ hệ chương và lời 2 của lại xe,
bùy nhiên bà đầu só tại sế tê khu qua sát,
không giữ khoảng cách,
không bao đảng tốc độ bị có thể dừng lại an quan,
dính đến tên an li khoảng,
kính chanh nghiên cứu khoảng mà tử ý và nụn độ cùng,
tại sế tê không bị phạm.
Tại sế tê xe bộ cho biết,
đã được kính xe ghí thịt của người sang kế phụ để lấy trái nước uống về khu qua sát và xe ra tài nạn,
không bị tịch lúc uống trình thật là xe.
Kính câu qua kể rất đưa trạc quan tình của hệ phòng tủy,
sắp mình làm sóng về nhân buổi tên an.